did you bring pilot Pete with you you
made just nudes career no I didn't know
I'm just so excited you all know what
we're doing on Monday night big night
Monday night big night my house yeah for
sure
okay can we talk about gretchen carlson
is here is so cool to see her and
bombshell was so in Crimea you embodied
those women but also you told a story
that needed to be told what was it like
making that well thank you first of all
um it was it was listened it's been a
great journey from the moment that we
got the script we weren't in this you
know this was before Harvey Weinstein
before me too and time's up was really
going and so it felt like a story that
was living in its own silo and yet we
look at us two years later and so i yeah
i mean i'm i do sync this movie in some
weird way will be a historical marker
for this movement have you talked to
Megan have you had a chance to chat with
her what is she what does she have to
say no I haven't I know she's seen the
film and she's tweeted about it and I
knew that it would be it's gonna be it's
hard for all of these women to kind of
have to relive it but the importance of
their story I think they understand what
that really means in the weight that
that carries Gretchen was thankful she
said she was so thankful and she
appreciated the moment and she thought
it was important but she loved the women
who portrayed the women in that movie
wow that's really nice cuz we haven't we
haven't really heard anything from her
so that's lovely to hear oh give her a
hug go give her a hug okay how much fun
is that when you get in that room and
you get to sit down you kind of get to
hang throw back a cocktail it's really
nice but I'm really nervous cuz I'm
sitting with Tom Hanks tonight and I
have to give him this Essel B deMille
Award and if you followed anything that
I've said in the last 25 years you will
understand how unbelievably
nerve-wracking that is for me tonight
because he's like he's my hero
and it all began with that thing you do
my second movie
so what does it mean what does Tom mean
to you because he is he's one of those
guys a lot like you though that can
morph into all these characters so
easily I just I I just he to me is the
like I just he's everything to me he was
the first actor whose name I knew really
he was the first actor whose name I knew
I never cuz in South Africa we there was
no like magnet celebrity magazines or
you didn't really like know about the
actors but I watched so many of his
movies that he was the first actor whose
name I know Wow okay real quick I'm
asked a couple questions
three hours ago I was only wearing Oh a
robe my favorite part of this look is oh
my my jewels
okay the one thing to get me through
tonight in my purse is gum okay okay and
first thing I'm gonna take off Cynthia
Revo actually brought in her purse and
she had a backup pair of underwear that
is suspicious I was like I was like wow
very smart
I mean I don't know what yes it's very
smart all right one last thing it is our
10,000th episode next week will you give
us a shout out for 10,000 episodes yes
congratulations
eg 10,000 episodes that is a tongue
twister Wow toaster cause but it should
be your your charity right oh my gosh a
thousand dollars will go to your charity
from a moet in your name see TRP is very
grateful thank you very much thank you
thank you for this is not gonna go over
my dress
[Music]
delicious what's the one secret you want
to after you've had that sit what's the
one secret you want to spill I really
don't like bees no I actually love bees
I love bees I just didn't think of
anything I have nothing I have nothing I
love bees save save every secret of
breath surviving Awards you know what
you need a good friend to like drag with
you everywhere and I have the project
someone the producer of bombshell was
like my best friend she's here with me
tonight is he you got you got a good
mate you're good to go get out of here
[Music]